[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy damos un vistazo a la
historia reciente de bolivia con
elecciones locales a la vista el próximo
11 de abril y su ex presidenta interina
jeanine áñez en prisión el país andino
intenta salir de una más de las crisis
que han caracterizado su turbulenta
historia política y social en el último
siglo
bolivia inició el siglo 20 habiendo
perdido en varias guerras buena parte de
su territorio y su acceso al mar a manos
de brasil y chile- entre 1932 y 1935 su
derrota en la guerra del chaco contra
paraguay
la despojo de otros 450 mil kilómetros
cuadrados aproximadamente el convulso
panorama fue caldo de cultivo para que
el héroe de la guerra del chaco el
militar germán bus asestará un golpe de
estado en 1935 pasados 17 años de
régimen autoritario bolivia se sacudió
en 1952 con el estallido de su
revolución nacional
por el movimiento nacionalista
revolucionario un movimiento que contó
con el apoyo de la clase media los
sectores mineros los indígenas y los
campesinos el movimiento nacionalista
revolucionario condujo a bolivia a un
periodo de progreso social y de
modernización política luego de tantas
batallas perdidas y de décadas de
inestabilidad bajo la presión popular el
estado liderado por víctor paz
estenssoro presidente en cuatro
ocasiones introdujo el sufragio
universal nacional hizo las minas de
estaño y lanzó una reforma agraria que
expropió a los terratenientes semi
feudales repartió la tierra de manera
más justa entre los indígenas y
campesinos y fomentó la educación rural
hasta que en 1964 otro golpe de estado
puso fin a ese período
bolivia entró nuevamente a una etapa de
dictaduras esta vez en gobiernos
intermitentes repartidos entre rené
barrientos y alfredo ovando un nuevo
golpe de estado ocurrió en 1971
encabezado por él
hugo bánzer en sus siete años al mando
van ser fue bastante más represivo que
sus antecesores al punto de suprimir el
movimiento obrero despojarlo de sus
derechos civiles y militarizar las minas
del país hugo answer dimitió en 1978
presionado por una dilatada huelga de
hambre de mujeres mineras y por la
oposición que lo acusaba de represor de
corrupto y de haber contraído una enorme
deuda extranjera lo reemplazó una junta
militar que se mantuvo por cuatro años
antes de ser derrocada en 1982 en aquel
año bolivia comenzó una serie de
gobiernos democráticos en medio de una
crisis económica severa cabe recordar
que para 1984 bolivia sufría una
hiperinflación superior al 20 mil por
ciento anual producto en buena medida al
profundo endeudamiento internacional el
desempleo aumentó del 20 al 30 por
ciento y llevó al despido de 23.000
mineros
estatales además los salarios
disminuyeron un 40% en un lapso de dos
años para finales de la década de 1990
la calidad de vida de la mayoría de
habitantes en bolivia rayaba en la
miseria el descontento social estalló en
violentos levantamientos populares como
el ocurrido en cochabamba en el año 2000
por la privatización del abastecimiento
de agua potable quien fungía como
presidente era de nuevo el ex dictador
hugo bánzer en una bolivia con huelgas
cortes de carreteras y enfrentamientos
entre el ejército y las comunidades
indígenas y campesinas contando a bánzer
que renunció en el 2001 en un plazo de 4
años se sucedieron 5 presidentes la
inestabilidad política la renuncia en
bloque de los ministros que no sabían
cómo recomponer la economía los
impuestos a los salarios y la
controversia por la exportación de gas
natural exacerbaron el sentimiento
insurrecto de las comunidades indígenas
para las elecciones de 2006 el creciente
movimiento indígena
una victoria ante el hastío de dos
décadas de partidos políticos
neoliberales fue elegido por una mayoría
absoluta del 60 por ciento
el líder sindical cocalero evo morales
el primer indígena en gobernar el país
bajo la bandera de su partido el
movimiento al socialismo más moral es
rápidamente nacionalizó la industria de
hidrocarburos y contó con la suerte de
recibir mayores ingresos por las
exportaciones de gas a razón de un alza
del precio internacional las políticas
de evo morales- frenaron la pobreza y le
dieron al país un crecimiento del 5 por
ciento en su producto interno bruto
durante sus primeros años de gobierno
evo morales fue reelegido por amplias
mayorías en tres ocasiones pero tras
insistir en una cuarta candidatura
presidencial y además de la denuncia de
un presunto fraude en los comicios
electorales de 2019 perdió el apoyo de
los militares y se vio obligado a
renunciar a exiliarse en argentina
durante su exilio bolivia fue liderada
por él
interino de jeanine áñez quien a lo
largo del año de pandemia de coronavirus
de 2020 aplazó la realización de nuevos
comicios electorales mientras la
justicia abría procesos contra evo y
varios de sus funcionarios finalmente
las elecciones se llevaron a cabo el 18
de octubre de 2020 dando por vencedor a
luis arce antiguo ministro de economía
de morales y candidato del más evo pudo
retornar al país el 9 de noviembre la
expresidenta jeanine áñez fue detenida
el 13 de marzo de 2021 acusada de
sedición y terrorismo por una presunta
conspiración de golpe de estado para
derrocar a evo otro episodio más de una
larga historia de golpes de estado
dictaduras y un pueblo que ante la
mínima crisis se levanta en masa hasta
aquí llegamos soy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]